bon la situation aujourd'hui moi j'ai
l'âme et américains là convient de
mettre voiture pour l aléa au port donc
les américains viennent viennent de
décoller la 18h heure locale une
trentaine de minutes nous la situation
s'est on devrait être rapatrié demain ou
après-demain situation que moi ne me
convient pas en tout cas c'est normal
qu'ils rapatrient les français moi c'est
un rapatriement pour l'instant j'ai
refusé parce que moi je suis
entrepreneur j'ai des responsabilités
ici savoir que j'ai une équipe de 14
personnes
même si tout est fermé que le climat
vont basculer des rues sont vides que
les commerces ont fermé et toubon va
revenir et être revenir pour être en
quarantaine dans un lieu qu'on ne
connaît pas pour une période
indéterminée parce qu'on parle de 14
jours mais ça peut si par malheur un
entre nous dans l'avion ou ailleurs a
été contaminée avant ou pendant le
pendant le confinement en quarantaine en
france les 14 jours peuvent se
transformer en un mois donc on voit là
moi pour l'instant je me sens plutôt en
sécurité
je sors pour faire mes courses il n'y a
pas du tout de kde de pénurie pour
l'instant donc voila moi je soir pour
promener mon chien pour faire mes
courses voilà aujourd'hui c'est assez
vaut donc plutôt agréable même si les
rues sont vides mais après moi voilà moi
je suis jeune j'ai pas d'enfants à
charge de base âge ni deux personnes
âgées
donc moi je suis plutôt confiant voilà
pour l'instant donc pour moi la
meilleure solution c'est de rester ici
awan d'attendre que ça se passe de
rester chez moi au maximum voilà
j'arrive quand même à voir des amis on
est beaucoup de français à être dans le
même dans le même immeuble
ça c'est plutôt bien et voilà mon espèce
n'a pas duré trop longtemps mais on
manque cruellement précision donc voilà
on sait pas combien de temps ça a duré
le gouvernement nous dit que ça peut
durer jusqu'au peut-être 14 février
minimum
on voit là ça peut s'étendre à un mois
un mois et demi on ne sait pas du tout
on attend des informations du
gouvernement local et voilà mais pour
l'instant il n'y a pas une urgence c'est
pas un rapatriement d'urgence c'est pas
moi je comprends très bien que les
salariés rentrent qui s'inquiètent pour
leurs familles pour leurs enfants donc
je comprends très bien moins en tout cas
dans mon cas je suis mieux ici à gérer
la crise sur place que être confinés
dans un hôtel ou dans un hôpital à paris
pendant une certaine période quand un
bon temps pour votre témoignage ont
longtemps vous